Every year, tens of millions of Americans
suffer from nerve damage, some irreparably
so.
Science can heal bones, grow new organs and
even restore our microbiomes, but why is it
so hard to fix our nerves?
Hey guys Lissette here for DNews
The human body posses a remarkable ability
to heal.
Bones re-fuse, skin wounds mend, and the immune
system adapts to infection, after infection.
But there’s one area of the body that struggles
to recover after an injury: The nervous system.
Nerve damage can be some of the most debilitating
and permanent type of injury.
The nervous system is an incredibly complex
network used to send electrical information
throughout your body.
It can basically be divided into two sections.
With the brain and spinal cord making up the
central nervous system or CNS…. and the
nerves made up of fibers of sensory and motor
neurons comprising the peripheral nervous
system.
Each cell in the nervous system from the tip
of your finger up your arm, up your spinal
column, into your brain, is very specialized.
And each has a unique function on the pathway,
like a circuit.
If one these gets cut or injured, it’s hard
for an exact replacement cell to be put in
in the right spot.
Think about when you get a cut on your skin.
If the cut goes deep enough, exact replicas
of cells won't cover the wound, instead fibrous
tissues form... which we call scars.
And scars are part of the problem in regrowing
nerves, they often get in the way - especially
in the case of spinal cord injuries.
As part of the CNS, spinal cord injuries are
notoriously difficult to heal; partially because
of the way nerve cells in the CNS are made.
According to the book, “Results and Problems
in Cell Differentiation”, the CNS also has
certain proteins that weirdly, inhibit cell
regeneration.
While this might sound like a bad idea, it’s
hugely beneficial overall to the formation
of the CNS.
These cells need to grow exactly where they
are supposed to, just one out of place could
be bad.
Like... think of an electrical circuit, each
unit has to be in a specific order in specific
place to work.
If one is out of place, the integrity of the
CNS is compromised.
Neurons in the CNS also lack certain cleaning
cells.
Nerve cells are made up of many parts, but
they send signals through threads covered
in a protective sheet of myelin.
These threads are called axons.
Axons are the long part of the cell that reaches
out to the cell next to it to send information
down the line...
Like arms handing the bucket down the line
in a bucket brigade.
So these are obviously super important and
need protecting.
That’s where the Schwann cells come in...
which are only found in the Peripheral nervous
system.
Schwann cells, which aren’t neurons but
GLEEL cells, produce the myelin that help
protect the axons.
But, a study published in The Journal of Cell
Biology found they also clean up damaged nerves
- making way for the healing process to take
place and new nerves to be formed.
But the problem is... these Schwann cells
are missing from the CNS.
What they have instead are myelin producing
cells called oligodendrocytes.
But these cells don’t clean up damaged nerve
cells at all.
Which is part of the problem.
So unfortunately, according to Dr. Richard
G. Fessler professor at Rush University Medical
Center "There are currently no therapies which
successfully reverse the damage" from injuries
to the spinal cord.
But research is currently underway to examine
the potential success of stem cell treatment,
where stem cells are injected directly at
the injury site.
Still, it will take a few years to see the
results of such trials.
But there are times your body can regenerate
nerves.
The peripheral nervous system doesn’t have
the same blocking proteins that the CNS has,
and Schwann cells help heal the damage.
So it’s able to regrow nerves, albeit slowly.
For instance, if you cut a nerve into your
shoulder, it could take a year to regrow.
By that time...the muscles in your arms could
become atrophied.
So, not surprisingly, researchers are working
on helping the body heal faster.
One study published in the Journal of Clinical
Investigation found that a shock of heat made
the peripheral nerves grow faster.
In another study published in the journal
Advanced Functional MATERIALS, researchers
used 3D printing to make a sort of guide for
peripheral nerves to follow as they regrew.
The guide was built with small physical grooves
and even chemical cues to help guide the nerve
along its new path.
But, to learn more about other research into
repairing spinal cord injuries, check out
Trace
in this
episode right here